[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new spider-man 3 marvel
video apparently Kevin Smith is saying
the daredevil is supposed to cameo
during spider-man 3 so we'll break it
all down there's some Easter eggs in
here obviously everyone's wondering what
Marvel was gonna do with the Netflix
characters after they canceled all those
series if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing an Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with daredevil inside the MCU so winners
break this down top 5 WTF style number 5
Kevin Smith is claiming daredevil is
going to appear during spider-man 3 is a
very notable very good lawyer
sympathetic to vigilantes and
superheroes and he's supposed to be
somewhere in the movie they haven't
started filming spider-man 3 yet Tom
Horn claims that they're going to start
filming in July despite what's going on
in the world right now with the virus
and how crazy things are getting at
Hollywood shutting down for about the
next two weeks as I'm posting this video
right after the spider-man far from home
post credits scene that Jay jonah
Jameson seen were Mysterio outs
spider-man's secret identity everyone
was saying spider-man will need to clear
his name wouldn't it be great if he got
a lawyer what other big Marvel
characters do we know that her lawyers
in sympathetic to vigilantes daredevil
wouldn't it be great at daredevil was in
spider-man 3 but at that point it was
still a rumor so I try to wait for more
official people to start talking about
stuff like this before I do videos for
it but because they haven't started
filming the movie yet that means that if
Kevin Smith is talking about someone on
the inside saying that daredevil is
supposed to have some kind of cameo
during spider-man 3
it means someone saw a draft of a
spider-man 3 script so keep in mind that
there are many different drafts in movie
scripts changed during filming sometimes
they'll start filming movies like
spider-man 3 before the script is
actually done so the plots of a lot of
movies changed while they're in the
process of making those movies there was
a big interview recently with Tom
Holland he was talking all about
spider-man 3 how the plot is really
crazy much bigger than the spider-man
far from home I did a separate video
about that so I'll link it at the end of
this but obviously there's a number of
reasons why a lawyer would come in handy
given the events of spider-man far from
home Marvel and Netflix cancelled all
the Netflix series two years ago a lot
of people wondered what
buguese plans were going forward for
those characters because some of them
are actually pretty big fan favorite
characters daredevil Luke Cage Punisher
Jessica Jones iron fist when they
cancelled all those Marvel issued
messages separately on all the different
Twitter accounts for those shows saying
that this would not be the end there
would be more stories to tell with these
characters like in the case of daredevil
they said daredevil will return Kevin
Feige has always been a huge fan of the
daredevil character he grew up on Frank
Miller's daredevil makes sense that he
would want to include him in some kind
of MCU project at some point a Disney
Plus series or a big Marvel movie the
reason why they didn't immediately say
what they were doing with those
characters right after they canceled the
series is because part of Marvel's
contract with Netflix for the Marvel
Netflix shows stated that if they
mutually decided to cancel the series
Marvel then could not turn around and
use the characters in other projects for
at least three years the official legal
term for that is a contractual
cooling-off period Netflix is always
going to be able to keep the episodes
for those series on Netflix I'm sure at
some point they'll be able to license
them to Disney Plus but they'll always
get to keep them on Netflix so number
four all the Marvel Netflix series were
cancelled during 2018 doesn't seem like
it's been that long but spider-man 3 is
being released during July 2021 which is
about three years after all the Marvel
Netflix series were cancelled outside of
that contractual cooling-off period
what oh he just wrote all of our names
didn't he how can you know that because
I was thinking the same so it seems like
they've met that requirement leaving
daredevil or Matt Murdock free to show
up during spider-man 3 in some kind of
cameo I'm sure there's a thousand other
pages of contractual stipulations that
we don't know about lawyers always make
everything more fun don't they but after
a certain period of time Marvel can do
whatever it wants to with the characters
again next big question number three is
Marvel going to officially canonize the
events of the Marvel Netflix series -
the MCU
regardless of where these characters
show up next a lot of the Marvel Netflix
stands will claim that the Netflix
series are already Canon - the MCU
but here's the thing about that you
can't really call them canon unless
major movie characters also show up on
the TV series which is why it's okay to
say agents of shield as canon - the MCU
because they have Coulson from the
movies he originated in the movies Nick
Fury originated in the movies and he
guest-starred during agents of shield
season 1 Cobie Smulders Maria Hill
character guest-starred during agents of
shield none of the real big Marvel movie
actors ever showed up on the Netflix
series and anytime they referenced
events of the movies or characters from
the movies they wouldn't use the proper
names it was really weird they called
the Battle of New York quote-unquote the
incident and instead of calling Captain
America Captain America Jessica Jones
referred to him as the quote-unquote
flag wear because his costume is red
white and blue with stars based on the
American flag like why wouldn't you just
call him Captain America the Russos did
say that they considered including
daredevil and some of the other Netflix
characters in cameos for Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame at one
point while they were writing the script
but this is the main reason for not
including them was they were just
already too many characters in those
movies and there were a lot of movie
characters that also did not make the
cut so it was a weird situation with the
Marvel Netflix shows like Kevin Feige
didn't really want to have to deal with
them he just wanted the daredevil
character I've never heard him speak of
Punisher in interviews but Punisher and
Luke Cage would be great anywhere they
want to put them I'll talk more about
what's going on with the future of the
other Netflix characters when Marvel
starts announcing more projects with
them number two if daredevil is shown
during spider-man three what's his role
how big is it gonna be and will it be
Charlie Cox's daredevil the way the news
sites and blogs are reporting this is
the highly skilled lawyer is supposed to
appear somewhere during spider-man 3
which makes it sound like if this winds
up being a thing
daredevil does appear during spider-man
3 it would just be Matt Murdock showing
up as a lawyer as part of the spider-man
3 plot where spider-man tries to clear
his name and prove to the world that
Mysterio framed him for his death the
funny thing about that storyline is that
whatever he does to clear his name
nothing he does is going to get Jay
jonah Jameson to back off this is the
way that character works even after
spider-man eventually clears his name JJ
will find some other thing to get mad at
him about can claims spider-man is
ruining the world it must be stopped
post all your j jonah Jameson spider-man
memes but it sounds like whatever
initial plans they may have had for a
daredevil cameo it really is just that
just a cameo he's not a major character
during the film so if daredevil winds up
showing up during spider-man 3 is
probably just a really really short
cameo but I sincerely hope that Kevin
Feige keeps Charlie Cox's daredevil
inside the MCU
he did speak highly of the daredevil
series in the past personally I don't
care if he recasts at least one of the
Marvel Netflix characters looking at you
Iron Fist but Charlie Cox was an amazing
daredevil so he deserves a chance to
continue as that character he even just
did a play with Tom Hiddleston in New
York and during Halloween last year they
went out as each other's characters Tom
Hiddleston dressed in a Netflix
daredevil costume in Charlie Cox bring
an MCU Loki costume everyone give a name
to this team-up right here what would
you call this TV show with Loki and
daredevil teaming up but number one WTF
what happens to daredevil after
spider-man 3 if he does show up during
spider-man 3 he's not really an a-list
Avengers level character and they won't
even do Avengers 5 for at least three or
four more years so where do they put
daredevil after he debuts in the MCU my
top picks right now are just some of the
other related Disney Plus series they're
getting ready to film she-hulk at the
end of this year she hooked Jennifer
Walters is a lawyer inside the Marvel
Universe who represents superheroes and
vigilantes because of the timing of that
the three year cooling-off period might
not totally be up so they might not be
able to use the
daredevil character but there's always
the moon night series and there's always
the opportunity that Marvel could just
do a new daredevil series on Disney Plus
people kind of wondered if they were
gonna do daredevil season 4 on Disney
Plus but I think in the name of
simplicity if they do a new daredevil
series on Disney Plus they would just
start as a soft reboot maybe keep some
of the characters I'd really love to see
kingpin show up in a spider-man movie so
hopefully at some point kingpin will
find his way into the MCU movies writing
your memoirs don't forget the hyphen
between spider and man but everyone let
me know in the comments outside of a
potential spider-man 3 cameo which movie
or Disney Plus series do you want marble
to put daredevil in next obviously
things are crazy right now with the
virus so I'll do video updates as we get
more information about what's going on I
just posted a big video about all the
movies that have been cancelled or
delayed move to other dates so I'll post
a link to that at the end of this as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all the videos
when I post them but congratulations to
Simon Bohan you're the giveaway winner
for my last big Marvel video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details make sure you
do that on desktop everyone click here
to learn about all the new movies that
have been delayed and canceled and click
here for my brand-new spider-man 3 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]